if you're excited for doctor strange to
face a famous squid monster you probably
left doctor strange too disappointed
and if you were excited about a certain
fan cast character you might have been
upset too these are the moments in the
dr strange sequel that upset fans the
most
warning spoilers ahead
a lot of the marketing for dr strange
and the multiverse of madness made it
seem like a monster movie with a
particular one-eyed eight-tentacled
creature looking like the potential big
bad some fans were already annoyed that
marvel referred to the character as
gargantos and not schumer gorath the
latter is one of dr strange's classic
adversaries from the comics while the
former is an obscure sea creature of
little narrative significance marvel
couldn't call the beast schumer gorath
in the film or sell any subsequent
merchandise because the studio doesn't
own the rights to that name so
filmmakers essentially brought the
schumer gorath design to life as
gargantos no matter what you call it the
monster doesn't turn out to be of much
consequence to the story it's pretty
easily dispatched near the beginning of
the film when dr strange using giant
projections of hands picks up a street
lamp and impales it right in its giant
peeper the eyeball with a disgusting
amount of viscera still attached
splooshes to the street below in one of
several moments that might be too much
for some viewers to stomach mostly fans
who are looking forward to a
creature-heavy feature were disappointed
that gargantos came and went so quickly
and some were surprised that wonder was
in fact the movie's true villain on a
related note some viewers criticized the
cgi in the gargantos battle though
others praise the overall design
the movie is called doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness but for some
fans and critics there weren't enough
universes and there wasn't enough
madness we only see the multiverse
depicted in its full trippy glory in one
sequence that was already heavily
featured in the trailer dr strange and
america chavez travel through several
universes including a paint world and
one full of dinosaurs in a matter of
seconds but they spend most of the run
time in just a few there's earth 616
earth-838 the universe that collapsed in
on itself from an incursion and the gap
junction where the book of vashanti is
kept safe which is more like a space
between realities on a film that's
ostensibly about infinite universes
that's a pretty modest number i think
audiences are going to be startled these
other realities invite a plethora of all
these new characters doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness is weird but
it definitely could have been weirder
especially given all the other worlds
alluded to in the film
honestly earth 838 doesn't look much
different than earth 616 except for the
abundance of flowers and greenery marvel
has been preparing its audiences for
high concept stories that play with the
bounds of time and space for years now
even casual mcu fans surely could have
handled more
ultimately even some fans who liked the
film feel that it didn't live up to its
title
for those who knew what to look for and
listen for the trailer for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
spilled the beans about both the
presence of the illuminati and professor
x's place among them we will see what
kind of doctor strange you are
nevertheless fans still gleefully
hypothesized as to who besides charles
xavier might be seated in those chairs
thanks to the film's title many
correctly assumed it was some other
universe's version of the secret
superhero society what many especially
non-comics readers didn't guess was that
earth 838's supposedly wise council
created and appointed by their own
doctor strange would be so condescending
and short-sighted about the threat wanda
posed in addition to professor x the
illuminati consists of karl mordo black
bolt captain carter reed richards and
maria rambo's captain marvel when
america travers and dr strange 616
bursts into their universe and start
looking for the sanctum mordo feign
surprise and delight before taking them
prisoner richards gets strange up to
speed about how the illuminati defeated
their thanos then delivers the bad news
that they've decided that he meaning
every strange variant is the most
dangerous being in the multiverse their
concern isn't unfounded 838 strange used
a dark hold to dreamwalk and killed a
trillion people in an incursion the
illuminati have no doubts they can
handle wonder who they quickly dismiss
their righteous smugness and failure to
listen which is admittedly on brand
taints their characters and it also
makes what comes next frustratingly
predictable
anyone who hope to see more than a few
minutes of the illuminati and dr strange
and the multiverse of madness will have
those hopes viciously dashed once the
scarlet witch arrives read richards who
is supposed to be the smartest man alive
overconfidently stands up to her and
stupidly gives away their secret weapon
he says that black bolt could destroy
her with a single whisper from his mouth
which is all the information wonder
needs to destroy them black bolt's death
is probably the most gruesome in a movie
that contains more than a handful of
brutal and controversial kills wonder
erases his mouth from his face which
panics him into imploding his own brain
she then turns reed into spaghetti cuts
captain carter in half with her own
shield and snaps professor xavier's neck
with her mind even if you don't mind
seeing these characters bite the dust so
easily their deaths are unusually
disturbing by the standards of the mcu
for some fans though it's not the
violence that's the problem but rather
the immediacy with which the illuminati
are dispatched a decision that makes
their inclusion in the plot feel more
like surface level fan service
john krasinski's short stint as reed
richards seems to have simultaneously
thrilled and upset everyone on the
internet fans of the actor have been
lobbying for him to play the mcu's
version of the character for years
krasinski himself has repeatedly
expressed interest in joining the mcu
particularly as reed richards so when
the office alum shows up as mr fantastic
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness it's a pretty big moment and
finally there's this four paneler which
i have to appreciate as it'll be the
closest i ever get to playing a comic
book hero
however many of the same fans who are so
excited to see krazynski in the role
weren't so happy when only moments after
his first appearance wonder rips him to
shreds with her chaos magic some have
taken solace in the fact that earth 838
is only one reality in an infinite
multiverse which means that krazynski
could and likely will reprise the role
in the mcu's upcoming fantastic four
film some of the actors fans were even
pushing for him to direct the movie
especially after the original slater
director john watts stepped away from
their production at this point however
few official announcements regarding
fantastic four have been made of course
krasinski isn't everyone's choice to
play reed richards some fans just
disagree that he's a good fit for the
part while others are put off by the
role that fan casting seems to have
played in his selection for them mr
fantastic's violent comeuppance was
satisfying and it gives fans who prefer
to see someone else on the role a little
bit of hope at least until more news
breaks about the cast are fantastic for
some audiences have taken issue with
what to them seems like a major
continuity problem created by doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
when strange is brought before the
illuminati he learns that they not the
avengers are the mightiest heroes of
their universe and that they have much
more working knowledge of the multiverse
than those in his home reality which
they referred to as earth 616 marvel
studios surely intended for this
numerical designation to be an homage to
the marvel comics where the primary
universe is also called earth-616 the
mcu is known to pull story elements and
shot compositions straight from the
pages of the comics but a lot of what
happens in the films isn't remotely the
same as the source material also the
main mcu timeline has previously been
referred to as earth
19999 as such the mcu's use of the 616
number has angered some fans and
confused others there's also an
additional continuity problem stemming
from spider-man far from home in that
film mysterio tells peter parker about
the multiverse and calls the avengers
reality dimension 616 claiming that he
himself is from earth 833 this is earth
dimension 616 i'm from earth 833 this
complicates things for a few reasons
first mysterio's story of being from a
different universe is a complete lie
second why would mysterio and the
illuminati people in completely
different dimensions who have never met
both choose 616 as a designator for the
main mcu timeline on top of all that
marvel seems hesitant to draw concrete
distinctions between words like
dimension a universe and reality
all of which are used in different ways
but also seemingly interchangeably
throughout the mcu
when the trailer footage for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
included shots of zombie strange many
fans assumed to be a nefarious presence
that dr strange would have to face off
against so when zombie strange ends up
being a good guy it's a surprising and
refreshing twist however the plot
mechanics that make zombie strange
possible have caused some division when
dr strange figures out what he has to do
to defeat wonder he tasks the christine
of earth 838 with protecting his body
while his consciousness is in the
reanimated corpse she has to defend his
physical form against the souls of the
damned who rise in objection to the
sorcerer possessing a dead body poor
christine gets little time to prepare
and no instruction on exactly how to
fight them off which some fans felt
amounted to shoddy writing the scene
does give raymie an opportunity to
sample from his previous work in films
like army of darkness and drag me to
hell but audiences who haven't seen
those movies won't benefit from the
references the result is a sequence that
can be wildly entertaining but also more
than a little confusing
in one of the best exchanges and doctors
strange in the multiverse of madness
wonder calmly argues that it doesn't
seem fair that both she and strange have
broken the rules in the past yes he gets
to remain a hero while she's painted as
a villain the scarlet witch goes on to
do awful unforgivable things but at
least at this moment in time she has a
point it doesn't seem fair though
elizabeth olsen turns in one of the
mcu's strongest performances nailing
both the nuanced intimate moments and
the big evil swings many fans were
surprised and upset by the fact that in
the end wonder isn't redeemed while
strange is the double standard is even
more apparent once we learn that the
finale's evil strange also used the dark
hole to look for universes in which he
ended up with christine granted wonder
does eventually see reason when her
twins from earth 838 appears so
terrified of her she chooses to destroy
mount wondergore and all the darkholds
across the multiverse still wonder's
hard term from avenger to power hungry
multiversal menace has rubbed many
viewers the wrong way specifically some
fans didn't appreciate the way wonder's
plotline seemed to play into toxic
tropes about overly emotional women the
scarlet witch does alternate between
hero and villain in the comics but many
who love the character think elizabeth
olsen's empathetic portrayal is far
better than the subpar stereotypical
writing to which she's long been bound
prior to the release of doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness the
multiverse was mentioned in the
spider-man movies and alluded to at the
end of one division it's also the whole
point of marvel's what if and a major
driver of loki season 1. because michael
waldron who wrote loki also wrote the
script for multiverse of madness it
seemed reasonable to expect some kind of
tie-in between the two the multiverse in
concept and name clearly breaks open by
the end of loki season 1. and the
introduction of jonathan magers as he
who remains aka kang foreshadows a wider
multiverse plot line down the road kevin
feige has confirmed that the events of
the loki's season 1 finale allow
spider-man no way home and multiverse of
madness to happen with all that in mind
plenty of fans were crossing their
fingers that would see kang loki sylvie
or some other reference to the disney
plus series in doctor strange 2. alas it
wasn't to be
loki didn't end up having a glorious
purpose as far as multiverse of madness
is concerned which some savvy mcu
theorists predicted well ahead of time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one